Caitlin Carter is getting candid about
her recent romance with Miley Cyrus I
had to prepare myself and decide like am
I gonna be okay with people just talking
absolutely everything I am in a new
essay Forel the 31 year old Hills new
beginning Starr writes about how she and
a quote female friend fell for each
other over the summer while they
traveled around Europe that super dope
and while she never actually calls out
Miley directly fans are connecting the
not so subtle dots quote this past July
I went on vacation with a female friend
the next thing I knew I was in love with
her of course Miley and Caitlin ignited
hot girls summer when they were spotted
together in Italy back in August I think
I can handle it I'm pretty good at
ignoring all that Caitlin adds quote
until that trip it had never crossed my
mind that I was even capable of loving a
woman the way I loved her the trip came
on the heels of Caitlin split from Brody
Jenner and Miley's breakup from Liam
Hemsworth yep something Caitlin says
brought her and Miley together quote as
my friend and I spent that August
traveling through Europe together and
trying to move past our respective
breakups my first and only romance with
a woman was born
oh but Caitlin didn't stop there she
wrote quote reflecting back on our
three-year friendship I realized I'd
always been drawn to her in a way I
wasn't with other friends but until that
trip it had never crossed my mind to
think of her in a romantic sense the two
split in September and despite the short
romance Caitlin says she'll remain
eternally grateful for the experience
adding that it was a profound journey of
self-discovery Caitlin also opens up
about her relationship with Brody whom
she split from in August do you guys
ever fight you don't seem like fighters
oh we definitely fight but
the two had a wedding ceremony in Bali
in 2018 we got married but never legally
tied to the knot so when you met him and
you guys fell in love did you know had
you watched the hills no I always I
actually was a huge fan of the show but
I was so focused on the girl I never
quote he became my best friend and
together we had all the fun at the world
had to offer
was it nerve-racking to be married and
putting that on Mon on TV because
reality TV in the past has not been
great for relationships in general I
feel like it actually helped us it not
helped us but it brought us closer
together because it was kind of like us
against the world in moments when
filming the show Brodie recently told ET
that their split will play out on season
2 of the hills reboot we didn't fight on
the shell Boat notice there was so much
outside you know we were we bicker that
we bicker a day we remember anymore
[Music]